what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i am back again
to talk about the latest developments
in the boku no hero story and man
this is bad this is really bad
i said in previous videos that the
villains look like they are gaining the
upper hand
once again and this was just confirmed
in a big way
not only that but after a very impactful
chapter that strongly implied
the death of an important hero character
we
just found out that many more heroes and
hero
students may already have been killed
off screen
this is basically deku's worst nightmare
and the worst case scenario for all of
japan
so let's get into it if you enjoy the
boku no hero content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going please 100
wyoming smash that like button and if
you happen to be new to anime outro
or you just haven't subscribed yet make
this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications a big thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons for making
videos like this one possible
i will talk more about patreon at the
end of the video but for now
please be advised that this video will
contain
boku no hero manga spoilers i am dealing
with
all of the most recent events in the
manga so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned okay
so the most recent chapter starts off
with deku doing his very
best to keep shigaraki restrained using
black whip
but shigaraki has somehow become even
faster and more
agile than he had been before instead of
becoming weaker
after taking all of that damage from
endeavour and the other heroes
shigaraki is somehow getting stronger
i'm guessing that this is related to the
fact that shigaraki
has now been awake for a longer period
of time you will recall that the
high-end nomu such as the female nomu
became stronger and more agile after
they'd been awake
for some time so the same is likely
happening with shigaraki
the more time goes by since his
awakening the more his new powers and
abilities are starting to manifest and
the more dangerous he becomes
as expected the heroes are all very
worried
about gran torino and they want to tend
to his wounds
as soon as possible but unfortunately
they have to take care of shigaraki
first
and that is no easy task and as deku and
ryukyu struggle to restrain shigaraki
deku realizes that shigaraki has a quirk
destroying bullet
deku recognizes right away what a
massive threat
this small object poses and he hits
shigaraki with a 100
wyoming smash the shock waves from the
impact
throw up dust and debris all over the
place and it is honestly pretty crazy to
see deku just using 100
so casually it makes sense because this
is a drastic situation
it doesn't get any more drastic than
this but i just have to point out that
deku
has definitely come a long way since the
beginning of the story
although to be fair so has shigaraki
also
shout out to wyoming that's not a state
you see mentioned very often
so if there is anyone watching this
video from wyoming
definitely drop me a line down in the
comments there's probably at least like
two of you out there
endeavor and bakugou then rush into the
aftermath of deku's smash
but as the dust clears we see that
shigaraki is still very much
conscious shigaraki had bitten down on
deku's forearm in order to keep deku
from blowing him away
and this came at the price of
shigaraki's lower teeth
all of shigaraki's lower teeth seemed to
have been smashed to bits
as a result of one for all's power
what's more
in the next few shots we see that
shigaraki did manage to launch
another bullet it appears that he had
more than one bullet stashed away
and this second bullet hits izawa right
in the left leg
just below the knee however the absolute
mad lad
isawa realized what was about to happen
and as the bullet hit him
he literally sliced off his own leg to
prevent the contents of the bullet from
spreading through his body
as he did this izawa thought of arie and
it was her
innocence and her smile that gave him
the strength to do what had to be done
in this crucial moment bruh this was
absolutely unreal we all knew that eizel
was a badass
but this move cutting off his own leg
without hesitation
was a whole other level of badassery
even shigaraki acknowledges how cool
aizawa is but shigaraki is also
determined to complete his mission
so he won't let his admiration for izawa
prevent him from doing what has to be
done
shigaraki is then able to break through
the hero lines and launch himself
forward
until he is literally touching aizawa's
face
deku manages to hold on to shigaraki
with a one-handed black whip
but shigeru is just too fast and strong
and deku cannot restrain him
on his own luckily just as shigaraki is
about to disintegrate isaac's face
into a million pieces a sudden barrage
of ice
tears into shigaraki and this pushes
shigaraki
away from izawa that's right our boy
shoto todoroki is finally on the scene
and he is ready to protect his teacher
at all cost
just like deku and bakugo deku uses this
opportunity to hit shigaraki with
another epic punch
and shigaraki is thrown further back and
away from
aizawa nevertheless izawa is clearly
injured and he has blood
running over his eyes deck when the
others are worried about izawa but he
isn't the only one that they should be
worrying about
due to the fact that isil had to close
his eyes shigaraki's quirks have
all been reactivated and as he stands up
after being hit by dekku we can see that
chicago's body has already recovered
from all of the massive damage that it
had sustained
just moments ago shigaraki proclaims
that despite their best efforts to
protect izawa
the only thing that awaits the heroes is
destruction shigaraki is confident that
victory is inevitable
and as the newly regenerated shigaraki
rises from the ashes
the chapter switches focus back to the
class 1a students who are working on
evacuating the civilians of jakku
as the students are wondering what
happened to todoroki since he had
apparently gone out to find
deku and bakugo an important piece of
news shocks the civilians
in the crowd ida asks one of the
civilians to turn up the broadcast
and the reporter announces that a
gigantic villain is on his way to jakku
this villain is destroying everything in
his path and it looks like he is going
to smash through
multiple cities before finally arriving
in jakku
uraka is surprised because she knows
that most of the pro heroes were
assigned
to keeping the villains from the mansion
at bay and
then the final page shows a transformed
gigantomachia about to smash
his way through a city and as this
happens oblivious civilians are going
about their day just meters away
blissfully unaware
that everything around them is about to
be destroyed
we can see that gigantomachia's body has
changed
not only did his jaw go up over his eyes
as we saw in previous chapters but his
hands
seem to have transformed as well it
appears that his hands have now expanded
in a way that makes them more suitable
for bursting through obstacles and
annihilating
everything in sight and unfortunately
we all know what this means this means
the plan
that the students try to execute back at
the mansion has
clearly failed for some reason the
sleeping agent did not have an
effect on machia at least not yet and he
was able to defeat the heroes and
continue his march towards jakku
this is really bad news for a lot of
innocent civilians
in makia's path and also for the heroes
and hero students in jakku
who already have their hands full with
the absolutely broken shigaraki
needless to say this could also be very
bad news for the heroes and hero
students who were trying to stop makia
back at the mansion
right before we saw that final page with
makia in his new form about to pummel
through a city
we also saw a couple of quick shots of
absolute
carnage near the mansion and we could
see people in hero costumes
lying motionless on the ground this was
the aftermath of the attempt by the
heroes and hero students to stop
machia the aftermath of the battle that
was happening back in chapter 280.
fat gum majestic mount lady gang orca
and other important heroes were all
there and attacking machia when the
focus of the story shifted back to jakku
and now the next thing we know all of
the heroes have been overpowered and
makia
is about to continue his journey after
leaving the heroes
and the hero students in the dust so
what happened what happened to all those
heroes
and what happened to the heroes students
did machia just kill a bunch of them
off screen did we just lose some of our
favorite boku no hero characters without
even realizing it i certainly hope not
but it's definitely possible that
makia's rampage
led to some serious casualties it's a
similar situation to what happened when
shigaraki destroyed the hospital
and an entire section of jakku city we
can't be sure yet because of all the
chaos
but it definitely seems possible that a
bunch of heroes died
this is some crazy stuff right here and
this is literally deku's worst
nightmare deku always wanted to save
everyone he wanted to protect his
friends
and innocent people what happened to
gran torino in the previous chapter is
bad enough
but now deku has to face an even more
tragic reality
izawa just lost a limb the heroes and
hero
students at the mansion might have been
killed thousands of civilians are now in
direct danger as makia plows through
multiple cities on his way to jakku
and of course shigaraki has been able to
regenerate once again
after gaining full use of his quirks at
least for the time being
obviously this turn of events isn't just
bad for deku
this is the worst case scenario for all
of japan
the last thing that anyone wanted was
makia leveling multiple cities and
killing who knows how many civilians
on his way to jakku but the reason i am
singling out deku in particular
is because he is of course the main
protagonist and he is also an extremely
emotional person who dedicated his life
to saving as many people as possible
the events of these last few chapters
are sure to fundamentally alter
deku as a person i mean just think about
it
when deku learns that some of his
friends might have been killed or
seriously injured when he learns what is
happening to civilians in all of these
different cities
and when he learns about all the pro
heroes who lost their lives
this man will never be the same again i
mean just remember how deku reacted when
one single hero
sir naidi passed away now with
potentially
thousands of people losing their lives
deku is going to blame himself for not
being able to do more
he is definitely going to take these
tragedies very personally
and i think it's safe to say that the
deku we knew from before the war arc
is now gone forever just like shigaraki
underwent a drastic character
transformation in the my villain
academia arc
deku is about to undergo a major
character transformation
as well he is about to come face to face
with
tragedy with his inability to protect
everyone
and with the dark side of the hero
society
and the pro-hero profession this is
shaping up to be
the worst case scenario this is deku's
worst nightmare
and the events of this war arc are going
to change him forever
please let me know what you guys think
did gigantomachia just kill
a bunch of heroes and hero students off
screen
or do you think that all of them were
somehow able to survive
how do you feel about shigaraki
seemingly gaining the upper hand in
battle once again
and what do you think is going to happen
next finally
how do you think deku is going to react
when he learns what just happened
at the mansion and also what is
happening to civilians in
other parts of japan because of machia
definitely share your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more boku no hero content
on the channel please leave a like to
let me know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime pro
or you just haven't subscribed yet
please make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a lot of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i wanna give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
a very special thank you to alpha sigma
a disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata alolan
adam the world acquired respect
pate heffa jonathan king brandon aviles
papa smurf emperor otaku thomas jones
kin mono and
admirath finally thank you to all of our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson king zeldris anatoly
kazotsky angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
octor jessica califond hinokai and water
bonnie parks ratheora florian joni
garcia
steelers deadly saint and stern hawkins
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you